All right,
welcome to the DDPS seminar. Everyone,
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics.
I have two announcements. First, please
mute yourself during the talk, but if you have
questions, you can unmute and ask questions or
use chat room to post your questions so
that we can address them in 20 session.
And finally, today's GDP seminar
is open to external audiences,
therefore no classified discussion is allowed.
So please watch out, that's about it. Now. Let
me briefly introduce our speaker today.
It is an honor to host Dr yasamin Bari,
who is a research scientist at Google DeepMind
with research interests at the interface of
statistical physics, machine learning and
condensed matter physics. In recent years,
she has worked on the foundations of deep
learning. From a physics perspective,
she has been an invited lecturer at the
last Haute Cher School of Physics, and was
a co organizer of a recent program at the Kavli
Institute for Theoretical Physics. Previously,
she received a PhD in Physics at UC Berkeley.
Today, yasaman will talk about a first principle
approach to understanding deep learning. I'm
sure we are going to hear a wonderful talk. Now,
let me ask a somewhat informal questions
to Yasmin, just to get to know you better,
Yasmin. So my question, as I warn you, will
be, you have a very interesting background.
You you have a physics major, pure physics major,
I assume yes. And then now you are in, you know,
computational science, and specifically the
machine learning and AI. How did it happen?
It happened somewhat organically. So my my PhD
thesis was indeed on kind of pure physics and
theoretical physics in quantum condensed matter
physics. But condensed matter physics has a long
history of condensed matter physicists have a long
history of, kind of going into other disciplines,
and there's really a broad notion of what
constitutes condensed matter physics.
It turns out that in the past, historically,
condensed matter physicists have also studied
neural networks as a part of the study of
disordered systems. And that's something
that you kind of was alluded to in
the Nobel Prize in physics that was
awarded this year. I got interested in it
organically. While I was still at Berkeley,
I kind of started to go to seminars in
the computer science department, and heard
about all this. And at that time, all of the
empirical advancements. And at that time, there
something that kind of came to the fore. Was it a
lot of people saying that it would
how important it would be to try to
understand at least something about
what these models are doing, and so
that as a scientific problem is
how I got started in the field,
and so I kind of worked on that problem
a bit more from like a physics angle,
either with methods from
physics or physics flavored
types of questions. And then more recently,
I've kind of wanted to also
explore, kind of go back a bit into
application. Applications
of of machine learning, to
to areas of the sciences that I know,
like condensed matter, materials,
molecular systems. And that's more of a more
recent development that I won't talk about,
but kind of bringing them back together. And
that second part is partly also, I think,
inspired by a lot of the advancements I've seen
now having worked at DeepMind or Google, first
Google Brain and DeepMind for some time, just
seeing those advancements and what they can do,
nice, nice. Well, yes, as you said, the
first Nobel Prize from the machine learning
person from the Nobel Prize physics. And
I hope that's going to happen more often,
and someday, maybe you're going to be a Nobel
Prize recipient from the physics field. Okay,
the stage is yours. Okay? Thank you, Yang. Su
for the kind introduction and the invitation.
So the focus of this talk will really be, as the
title says, taking a first principles approach
to trying to understand deep learning. So
rather than talk about methods specifically
from the physical sciences, I'd like to
just give a little bit of a survey or over.
View of some of my work, and more broadly, things
that would be interesting for scientists who work
with data driven methods in general and and, and
how, at least, there's been some progress made in
understanding some pieces of this big landscape
of, you know, big design space of neural networks
and AI, where there are just so many knobs and
so many choices to make at least something about.
Some of that has been understood recently, and
I'd like to share a little bit of that with you
in hopes that it might kind of influence,
maybe your research in the physical sciences as
well. So as you all know, you know there's this
ever persistent promise of machine
learning and AI and also some
real successes from the past
few years in the sciences,
as you know, in protein structure
prediction, like the Alpha fold model
and developing neural network based DFT
functionals, for example, and as well as
developing increasingly large language models that
can do some amounts of math and science reasoning
in certain domains and certain types of problems.
So these have all been big advancements from big
models in the last few years. But I'm
going to now maybe take a different
angle to in this talk, which is, what do
we understand about deep learning and how
it works and how to design models? And I
would say, along with all this empirical
progress that has happened. I feel that on the
understanding side, were quite a bit behind.
And, you know, just a few years ago, at one of
the main ml, major ml conferences, you know,
one of the invited speakers, very famously made
this illusion that deep learning is not really
a science or in engineering, it's
alchemy. It's just mixing things,
you know, designing models in a somewhat
unprincipled way without, you know,
the designer knowing exactly what will work or
what won't, and having some basic principles.
So I think, you know, the unanticipated success
of using neural networks as models forces us
to consider some new questions and also revisit
some old ones from just machine learning from the
past few decades. So the types of questions
I want to kind of address in this talk are,
what can we say about what neural networks
actually learn, if anything at all? So this
problem turns out to be solvable in
certain regimes which can be useful.
Why is it that neural networks with more
and more parameters perform better? So
there's been this trend in the
field to make a models bigger,
and often either models wider or wider and deeper
and so on. And this kind of runs counter to this
old intuition from just statistics. But as
as scientists, when you think about fitting
any data, the more parameters you use, you
worry about overfitting. And somehow this runs
completely counter this. Trend runs completely
counter to that. And then the third question is,
what controls the gains from scaling up
deep neural networks as we increase the
amount of data or the size of the model and so on.
So in the first part, I just want to give a bit
of an overview of a topic that I've worked on,
but that, I think is more broadly, could be
broadly useful to scientists who also do a
lot of scientific modeling, which is some
results, some correspondences that we built
between neural networks and Gaussian processes,
which I won't describe in a lot of detail,
but maybe some of you are familiar with, it's
sort of a very different modeling paradigm
to
to the training of neural networks.
So just to set up the basic problem,
let me consider a just a vanilla neural
network. But we can do this for a lot of
different architectures, a fully connected
deep neural network, which has a certain
depth L to the computation that it does,
and it has a certain hidden layer with n,
which is essentially how many computations
it's Doing in parallel at the same time. And
so we can describe, you know what the
computation done by this network is a
recursion relationship where the function f is a
function of the original input data x coming in,
and we take the signal FL minus
one, which is also a function.
Of x, let's say, at coming in here, we pass it
through a non linearity phi. We multiply by weight
matrices, which are our learnable parameters in
this network, and maybe a bias. And we do that
to construct this signal at the next layer. And
this continues through the through the network.
So this computation, as I mentioned, it has
a depth to it, and it has a network width,
where, here you sum over all these contributions
from the different hidden nodes or
neurons from the previous layer.
Now, in general, being saying, being able
to say something about this computation is
pretty challenging. It depends on a
lot of the hyper parameters. But it
turns out that at large n in this so
when you take the limit of a large
number of hidden nodes or neurons, the
description of the system simplifies.
So you can kind of see that through
the central limit theorem and or
other more rigorous techniques. But
essentially what happens is, at large n
you sum over very many
variables here, and that sum you can when, when
you start with at least at the at the beginning
of training, a random network will involve the
sum over many random variables. And you can
imagine how you apply central limit theorem
to that to be able to describe the process
F. So this kind of ties in. Basically, it's
studying the statistical physics of large and
deep neural networks at the moment, just when
they're randomly initialized. So we're just,
we're you can think of it being at the
beginning of training, we initialize
the parameters randomly, and then we want to be
able to describe the system. But I'll talk about
training in just a minute, because it turns out
we you can just easily then get to that as well.
So this is also, you can think of it as a type
of mean field theory that becomes exact in the
infinite width limit. So the conclusion is
that at the large in the large end limit,
when the network width is wide enough, this is
well described by a Gaussian process. This neural
network, and what we need to describe a Gaussian
process is just a mean and a covariance function.
So it's just described by its low order
statistics. So it turns out that that's
also pretty natural, easy to calculate. So
there's some recursion that happens on the
space of functions as you go through
one layer of the network to another,
which I just described. It's
this Iterative computation,
but if you were going to calculate the covariance
function, so the expectation of f of x times f of
x prime averaged over the network, this is what
you need to be able to describe the to construct
the kernel function of the Gaussian process.
It turns out that that also obeys a recursion
relation. So for from F naught, you can compute
a k naught, from f1 you can compute a k1 and so
on until you get to a final K. This covariance
function, or kernel function, is a function of
two inputs, x and x prime. So just as a
maybe reminder so a Gaussian process I mentioned
needs a mean function and a covariance function.
The mean function in this setting is just
zero. The covariance function is a function
of two arguments, x and x prime. It tells
you roughly how similar X and X prime are
after you perform this series of computations,
and there's a recursion relationship that you can
get for K that exactly mirrors the one we wrote
down for F, because it's done iteratively, it
inherits the computation that the
neural Network inherently is doing.
So this is a way, a natural way, in which Gaussian
processes and kernels arise from neural networks
naturally, and they have a certain structure
that's different from kernels or Gaussian
processes that were known before, because they
have this compositionality in them. And you know,
classic yacht processes in the literature
and textbooks, if you look at them,
have a very different structure. They're
usually constructed from simpler functions,
and they're not compositional in
this way that I described. So.
So now that was the study of random networks,
but once you map the problem over to a Gaussian
process, and that description is exact, as
I mentioned in that limit, and it's a good
description, if the layer width is large enough,
then it's easy to do Bayesian learning from that.
So if you have a data set D, and you'd
like to make Bayesian predictions from this
neural network in this large width limit, you can
essentially do that through this Gaussian process,
for example. So these are now well
written, you know, kind of textbook,
Gaussian processes. There are equations that you
can look up for what the prediction would be after
learning on a certain amount of data, for the for
the network or for the model. So, for example,
the output of the function on some new point
x is it's a probabilistic computation. So it's
described by some distribution. In this case, it's
a normal distribution with a mean and a variance
that you can write down analytically. And for
example, the mean is just gotten by computing this
linear algebra, you know, computation on the tart,
on the original targets, y, at the data points
that you have, and doing some linear algebra using
this kernel function that I described on the prior
slide. So for every network, every neural network
that you have, you have this kernel function k you
can compute it on your training data, just
as you would for other Gaussian processes,
and then you can use that to make predictions.
And so this became a way of obtaining Bayesian
predictions that are exact from an infinitely
wide, deep neural network. And pictorially for
those of you, just as a maybe reminder of Bayesian
kind of methods and what a Gaussian process does.
You know it's probabilistic,
so before you learn from data,
you have some kind of distribution
over the values of the function
with some mean and some variance. But after you
learn from data, your function kind of reduces
its error around those data points to match
the values y that it's regressing to. And then
there's some remaining variants in the places in
input space where you don't have a lot of data,
but you would need to, you know, have
more constraints, to do better learning.
And so in summary, this was kind of
a few year program, essentially to
take neural networks of different architectures,
so this zoo of architectures that exists out there
with all sorts of different models
and derive, in this large end limit,
the Gaussian process and kernels that
originate from those. And we did that at
the very beginning with our very first paper
on just the fully connected neural network,
which gives rise to some kernel k, which I
label FC, just to just to say that it it's
tied to the architecture of a fully connected
neural network. You can do something similar
with a convolutional neural network. So
these are often used in vision problems.
There the notion of what is n, what is the large
width limit is slightly different. It's the number
of filters that you use. But again, it's always
corresponding to this sequential process, sorry,
parallel processing that you're doing
in every layer at the same time. You
can also do it for models with attention
layers that are now used in you know,
it's kind of like the backbone of language models.
You can do it with residual networks that have
skip connections. You can also do it with graph
neural networks as well. And so this kind of had a
number of implications. So I focused here
more on the methodology that originate. That
was one of the consequences of these mappings. So
now you have Gaussian processes and kernels that
you can just use. And it turned out that
they were, at the time, state of the art
Gaussian processes compared
to like older, traditional
GPS, for example, the fully connected one
that we published the begin some time ago,
at the time was was like a state of the art
GP, and same with convolutional. And again,
I think this, the reason for this is
that it's a richer class of kernels.
Or GPS, because it has this compositional,
hierarchical processing that comes from the neural
network that usual Gaussian processes with simple
kernels like radial like Gaussian kernels or,
you know, radial basis functions don't have.
So one aspect of this, as I mentioned, was
one consequence of this program was
methodological. So now we have
these methods that we can use
in lieu of traditional Gaussian processes.
The second, which I won't go into, was it kind
of gave rise, on the theoretical side to the to
to even more work on these large width limits.
And so there have been a lot of consequences
coming from that as well, which I won't get
get into but, but some of those highlights
have been that the community was able to actually
solve for the dynamics of optimization exactly
in that limit. So there are other very
closely related kernels that you can write
down and construct that describe what happens
under optimization in this large with limit.
And so this has given people a theoretical
handle on the problem in that limit. It also
has given rise to kind of a whole sub field
in in machine learning, having to do with
setting parameterizing networks, layer widths,
layers in a right way, so as to either be close
to this limit or not be close to this limit.
And I won't get into that either, but just
allude to this fact that this has kind of gone
off and evolved into other directions as well.
On the methodological side, I'll say that.
So I talked more about the theory, but if
you're interested in using any of these models,
there was sort of a larger effort at Google to
construct a library that would allow you to easily
implement these kernels and Gaussian processes,
kind of in in correspondence with neural network
layers. So in the same way that we have libraries
for neural network layers where we can define, you
know, fully connected layer, convolutional layer
and so on, now you can do that in a way to you
can define networks and at the same time define
these kernels and be able to compare them,
sort of apples to apples. Jax is a really nice
framework, also developed at Google. So
this library, the neural tangents library,
is written in Jax, and it's very easy to use,
so I encourage everyone to play around with it.
You just import its neural network library,
and you can define a neural network here,
like a sequence, for example, of just weight
matrices and ReLU function non linearities,
and be able to obtain both the kernel function
and the actual neural network function, train
them and then compare, compare them. And so we did
this also pretty systematically across different
architectures. And for each case, it turns out
that whether the finite size neural network,
or the infinite with kernel does better really
depends on the architecture and the and the type
of data. So for example, you may this might run
counter to your wisdom, but in the case of fully
connected neural networks, it turns out that that
the kernels do pretty well on like the simple
benchmark data sets coming from the vision you
know, very simple image classification data sets.
And I think one reason for that is because
fully connected neural networks at finite
size are actually not very good models. They
don't have rich inductive biases. They don't
have a lot of structure that's actually relevant
for the physical world. And so the infinite with
neural network is something that has infinitely
many basis functions in it, and it actually does
either on par or as well, you know, as well as the
finite size neural network. Now what we found was,
if you go to other architectural classes,
like Convolutional Neural Networks,
which do have structure, more structure in
them that's well suited for the physical world,
then the finite size neural networks do do better
than the kernels, but it's also important that you
have enough data for that to be true. So a general
trend that is now kind of known in the field, or
has kind of grown out of that is, is that
these finite size neural networks that
that we're all using to.
A do do really well, but you do really need a
certain amount of data for that to be true. And if
you're in a low data regime, you actually it may
not be the case that a model which is infinitely
large and is just a kernel, since that's a
somewhat it's a very particular class of models,
a model that is just a kernel can actually do
that corresponds to the same structure of the
finite size neural network can actually do
as well. So there's some crossover between
as a function of the amount of data that
you have, between whether a kernel method
is good and whether a neural network is good.
So that's sort of a high level takeaway from
the systematic comparisons of basically having a
one to one correspondence between infinite size
models and their finite size versions
and their finite size versions. When,
when you know, as I just to reiterate, when
you do have rich structure in the model
that matches that of the physical world.
The finite size network does do better,
because it adapts its basis functions to
the data, and a kernel does not do that. I
want to ask a quick question like,
how many parameters does this equivalent
caution process kernel has like?
Because that seems to be the
key issue for data, right? So
do you have any comment on that? So it only
has in terms of tunable parameters? These
would the hyper parameters it would have,
just for example, in these vanilla settings,
just the like a, I didn't write it on the
slide, I guess, but a like a weight variance
and a bias variance, so two constants
that come from sort of the scale that
you want to choose for your prior on W on a
scale for the prior on the B's. And a lot of
the ones we tested were kind of this. They're
essentially two parameter Gaussian processes.
Then we tune those two hyper parameters. But
the neural network does have, in principle,
a few more design choices as
well that we tune. Okay, okay,
and that's where the more data requirements
come from, you know, for the neural network.
No, the more data requirements seem
to come from. Well, it's actually not
well understood theoretically or just why, but
it's more of an empirical observation where,
if you're the thing with a kernel is that it has a
if a neural network is allowed to learn?
Yeah, if
I guess, I guess I would agree. Maybe that
is a way of stating it you need more data to
it's better if you can adapt your basis functions
quite a lot to the data. But in order to do that,
you do need more data. Okay, yeah, that's
sort of the Yeah, maybe the rough idea.
Thanks.
Any other questions?
I don't see anyone, hands up, so you can
so, so that kind of is just,
was an overview of this area,
in case you want to read more about it or use some
of the tools. Now I'll just
switch gears to a different
kind of more recent evolution, which is trying
to understand scaling laws in in machine learning
models in general, but particularly neural
network models, and especially when they're
large. And so I'll give a bit of an overview on
that as well. So, you know, you have these basic
knobs in machine learning that you can tune
to adjust the performance of an ML model. So
amount of training data that you have, which
is often small and scientific applications,
is is one of them. But you also have the
size of the model as well as the amount
of time you want to train for. Or another
way to state that is, you can change units,
especially essentially, and instead study the
amount of computational resources you have to
devote to that. So like the amount of flops
that you you would like in a computation. And
nowadays, in the era of at least in the in the
space of very large machine learning models,
there were a few empirical observations a
few years ago that kind of just highlighted
a very simple trend, but one that's very
useful to measure, which is just that the quad.
Quality of your model as measured
by the test loss after training
seems to improve rather monotonically as
a function of any one of these variables
in the problem. So the amount of
computational resources you have,
the amount of training data and the number
of parameters and these trends sometimes,
although not always, seem to be like power
laws with certain exponents to that scaling.
There are, of course, other knobs that
you can also tune, which I won't discuss,
like the quality of the data, how heterogeneous
it is and what mixtures you should take.
But for now, I'll just focus on
these empirical observations.
Some other examples of this,
which you might be familiar with,
are also in the in the space
of large language models. So
you know, GPT three, one of the things that
was originally observed about it was that you
know certain performance benchmarks can can
improve monotonically as a function of, say,
the size of the model or the amount of data
and so on. But there's other regimes, other
types of problems where you
can have sort of discontinuous
behavior. And so, for example,
one of the observations was, if you take,
let's say you take some relatively smaller model,
and you look at the accuracy as a function of the
amount of examples that you give in context to
this model. So now we're thinking of language
models. They have some they're trained on
some pre training data set, some corpus, but
they can do in context learning. So after
they're trained, you can give them some
few examples. You know, that's how you interact
with say, chat G, chat G, P, T, or any of these
large language models available now, you give
a few examples, which is, you know, the number
of examples in context, and you can look at the
how the performance improved as a function of the
number of examples in the context. And sometimes
what, what was, what was observed was that if you
continue increasing the size of the model,
there's a point at which you actually
get some discontinuous behavior
as a function of the number of examples
in the context. So for this ultra large,
almost absurdly large, you know, model,
what you find is that the accuracy as a function
of the amount of data in the context improves
and then kind of transitions to to
a different slope, but at large,
much larger values of the accuracy, as you
give it more and more examples. So this is
the kind of behavior that at least model
designers in this in this other regime,
which I know is somewhat different from scientific
applications, which are much more small scale,
but this is sort of the regime that
people are working in nowadays,
in the space of large language models,
or even models like alpha fold and so on,
which have a lot of training
data and very large size,
but there's a lot of empirical work, essentially,
to try to figure out the best way to scale up a
model. So if you have some amount of resources
that you want to devote to training a model,
let's say you have a fixed amount of
computational resources that you're
willing to spend, then there's an optimal
way to allocate that those resources to
either to some amount that you should pick
the amount of training data that you need
in a specific way, and you can pick the model
size in a specific way. And there's some trade
off. If your model, for example, is too small
relative to the amount of data that you have,
then you may not actually be getting all of
being able to extract all the information that
you could from that data set, or vice versa,
if your training set is too small relative to
the size of your model, you don't actually
have enough information for the you know,
the richness of the model. You have many more
parameters that you could be using that you're not
essentially using. So there is a bit of a trade
off here, and the community has been looking at
figuring out the best ways to scale
up so that it's compute optimal.
I won't go too much into the details of what.
We've looked at, but we we
did some theoretical work, essentially trying to
analyze what gives rise to these scaling laws,
what what controls these trends?
And this is important for any model,
even in the physical sciences. So often you're
interested in the physical sciences is in you
have a fixed amount of data, and you just
want to know how good is the model right now,
the quality of the fit. But it could be that
you're in a situation, maybe you're working
with experimentalists or something, where you
could potentially obtain more data over time,
let's say, and then the model that you would want
to choose is actually not the model that has the
best fit right now, it's the model that whose rate
of improvement is actually pretty good as well. So
it's just another metric to look at, because you
might be able to do more with with such a model
if you had just a little bit more data, or just
a little bit bigger model in terms of its size.
So I'll maybe just skip a bit over this,
since it's maybe a bit too much kind of in the
there's, there might be a question on the
chat, but I'll, I'll, I won't go into the
details of this, just to say that we
looked at this problem theoretically,
looking at the loss as a function of the amount
of data D, and for us, the model size, but it was
related to the width of the neural network.
And we were able to derive these power laws
as a function of the amount
of data D or the model size,
and they have certain exponents, which
is what I'm highlighting in color. So
that's telling you about this rate
of improvement, alpha d or alpha W.
The short of it is, is that one of the things we
found, which I can summarize as a just high level
rule of thumb, is that if you have, if you're
looking at scaling one of these parameters on
its own, either the amount of data that you
have or the size of the model. So D or n,
there are different regimes
of scaling that kick in. So
what happened? What happens
is that if you're scaling up,
if you have these two variables
d and the variable n1,
of them will be the bottleneck in the scaling. So
let's say it's a very intuitive rule,
but let's say you're in this regime so
the amount of data you have relative to the
size of the model. Where this constant is
not something we know, but it's, it's some,
you know, rough regime where this is true.
Then if you look at the data sites, data says,
data set, size, scaling, D. So what happens if
my model is large? I'm I have a certain amount
of data, and I want to increase the amount of
what would happen if I increase the amount
of data, you get some particular exponent,
alpha d, we call this. We gave this, this regime
a name. It's called resolution limited. It has
to do with how well you resolve the data
manifold, essentially. So this exponent,
alpha d is actually pretty complicated.
It depends both on the data and the neural
architecture. And I'll mention, I'll give some
few examples of what controls this power law.
The exact same idea is true if you now switch the
roles of the variables. So now let's say you're
in this regime where you have a lot of data, you
have a small model, and you're just looking at
the what happens when you scale the size of the
model. Again, the model size is the bottleneck,
and you get some exponent, alpha, W, which is
complicated in general, one should go measure it,
but, but it has to do with, again, this resolution
of of a data manifold. But if you're in this
other regimes, which I'm in this table, I'm
putting on the diagonals. So for example,
if you're in this regime where you
have a certain model size and you
have a lot of training data, if you
keep increasing the amount of data,
your exponent, the rate at which you improve is
actually just some fixed constant equal to one.
So the gains you know from this are kind of
potentially a marginal or not. And something
similar happens when you again reverse the two
variables. So at a high level, this is all just
to say that you can partition this space of
2d, space of data scaling and model scaling
into different regimes. You can categorize them,
and you can understand that certain regimes are.
Actually a quite related to each other and B, you
can understand what controls the scaling in those
regimes. And then there are other regimes where it
really has to do with how well you model the data
manifold and so on. So these are just empirical
results to kind of demonstrate that we see these
exponents alpha equal to one in these diagonal
regimes, regardless of what the problem is. So
these are like different data sets, different
models. They all improve at the same rate, alpha
equal to one. Same with this down here, but on
the off diagonals, which correspond to these other
regimes, we see very problem dependent exponents.
So that's sort of the high level takeaway.
I'll say one final thing, which is
that the power laws in these regimes,
on the off day, off diagonals that you have are
actually related to power laws that you see in
the data. So if you take, and this is maybe
more details than something I'll get into.
But if you take those kernels that I showed you
alluded to earlier in the beginning of the talk,
and if we want to just study, let's say, the
scaling of a Gaussian process or of a kernel
method, it turns out you can understand
that pretty well, and it's very related to
the properties of the kernel when it's evaluated
on training data. So, for example, imagine
that I take one of the kernels, let's say the
kernel from the fully connected network that I
had earlier in in the large with derivation.
And I just want to understand what is the
data scaling of a model with that kernel
like what controls that? This is actually
a better understood problem, and in this
case, you can actually be pretty precise
about what controls it. One of the big factors
is just the eigenvalue spectrum of that kernel
matrix when you evaluate it on the training
data. And if you look at real data, one of
the properties, unlike many theoretical models,
is that one of the properties it displays, is
that it has a power law dependence. So if I look
at the eigenvalues lambda i as a function of i,
there's some power law behavior as a function
of the index i of the eigenvalue that power lot
depends on the difficulty of the data set
and the structure of the kernel. So here,
just to tune the complexity of the data, what
we're doing is coarse graining image data. So
so for example, as we go from one to 14, what
we're doing is taking images, and, you know,
coarse graining them, so just averaging
them locally until we produce images of
lower and lower resolution. And that produces
that's as we go up to these pink numbers,
and that changes the spectrum of the kernel,
because it changes the complexity of that
data set and the task that you have to
perform, which is interpreting either
a high resolution image or a low resolution
image. So this is all just to just to say that
or highlight that these how a model scales
its scaling behavior, and these power laws
in some of these regimes where
it's very data dependent,
it depends on the data manifold can be tied
back to power laws that originate in real,
natural data, like the real world has
power law data in it. When you look at
what it looks like in these covariance
functions or kernel functions,
okay, I'll maybe skip over some of the predictions
that come. There's there's more details of
of of our theory and what we predict. But again,
the the takeaways, we can observe these different
regimes with exponent alpha equal to one, as
well as exponents that are very different and
dependent on the problem. As you see here, alpha
d, that is around point two. Alpha p, again,
around point two, this is now in a setting
which involves pre training and fine tuning,
so it's a pretty practically relevant setting. So
I'll skip over these. I'll just say that there's
also these connections between scaling and
the dimensionality, effective dimensionality,
of the data manifold. And so we've done, we
had done experiments where we looked at the
correlation between the data scaling exponent
and the dimensionality of the data manifold,
and essentially alpha d goes as
one over the effective dimension
of the problem.
Problem, and you can see, for different data sets,
at least, there's a rough correlation in that,
the larger the dimensionality,
the harder the problem and the scaling.
So
just a few other empirical observations
that might interest you again? If,
if you were to look at scaling
for any models that you work with,
but modifying the task affects the
scaling, of course. So for example,
let me point to this example on the
right. If you corrupt data with noise,
then it becomes more difficult, and
the scaling of that same model as you
increase the noise. So those are the kind
of the blue numbers, the scaling worsens,
both the num both the curves shift upwards, but
their slope also changes. So the efficiency of
the model on that data set is much worse.
On the other hand, if you actually just
change the task to be something that's kind of
semantically very similar to the original task,
you don't change the efficiency, at least
within these experiments, you just shift the
curves up and down.
You can also look at architectural differences
within certain families of neural network models.
So this is like a very classic ml setup, where
you have a wide ResNet model. It's a family of
models that you can make deeper or wider, and
you can look at the scaling on real data sets,
and what you find is depth, again, kind of roughly
shifts the curves up and down, but if you change
the width quite a lot, and as you make the network
wider, it actually has a worse slope. Actually,
this is connected to what I mentioned earlier
about the efficiency of kernels compared to neural
network models. What these curves essentially are
doing is the pink one is, say, a neural network
model of a particular width, and as we increase
the width, we actually get closer to these kernel
regimes and kernels don't scale as efficiently
as neural networks once you have enough data,
and you can see that worse efficiency
here, data efficiency in this blue line.
Finally, I'll just mention that another
kind of very connected emerging area is,
how can we? How can you do better
than the power laws that you have
that are kind of fixed, you're stuck
with depending on the model that you
choose and your data set. And there, it's
known that you could beat the scaling laws,
the power law form, if you sub select
your data in a very strategic manner.
So if like somehow you knew which data
would be the right ones to select,
you could actually get this kind of Sigmoidal
improvement as a function of the amount of data.
It levels off at some point. But for very small
data sets, that means that it's much better to
actually, you know, strategically sub select the
data, rather than use all the data that you have,
kind of randomly sampled IID from, from your
set. And so figuring out the way to do this is
sort of a it's a continuing area of research, but
something to keep in mind, especially when you,
when you are in these data limited regimes, or you
can, you know, wisely choose the data or where to
sample if you're doing active learning and so on
in these in these settings. Okay, so maybe just to
summarize kind of the two portions of this talk.
And thanks for your patience and interest, because
this was more focused on, sort of like, what are
the foundational principles we kind of understand
on on of neural networks and ml at the moment?
And I just wanted to kind of reiterate these two,
which was the first was that neural architectures,
very general class of neural network models,
different architectures, all naturally give rise
to Gaussian processes and rich compositional
kernels that can be useful as methods.
They're more useful in low data regimes where
traditionally Gaussian processes and kernels are
used. I think if you're gonna, if you do use such
models, it's worth considering these compared to,
compared to traditional Gaussian processes with
traditional kernels, because there's a good chance
these might do pretty well for your application,
like one, one other difference in a.
Addition to the compositionality that
I actually forgot to mention is that
these kernels are non local kernels. Local
kernels like a natural radial basis function,
so it gives larger weight to inputs in the
feature space that are closer together,
but neural networks and their associated
kernels are in some ways more powerful models,
because it allows you to give a correlation,
a similarity to features that are potentially
very different in their original input space,
even though they're similar in some higher
dimensional, non linear space. So non locality
is actually another way in which these kernels are
different than kind of traditional kernels. They
can be useful for Bayesian modeling
if you want principled uncertainty
estimates or marginal likely likelihood
estimates and so on. And then the second
topic that I talked about was thinking about
scaling laws, so kind of just the changing
perspective from not just how well does the
model do right now with my fixed setting of
a fixed amount of data and a fixed model size,
but if I change these knobs Just a little bit,
which models are actually more efficient? And
if I could get to that regime, then they would
actually be better models, so that, as a is
another angle for model comparison. And then
also thinking about Data Selection strategies,
so that you can scale better than the kind of
default power law scaling that that you would
have if you, if you just sampled data randomly,
IIT. And with that, think I will just
thank you for your interest. And that
kind of wraps up everything I wanted to to
tell you about today. Thank you, fantastic.
Wonderful talk,
but we have a quick questions. I
don't know you can see that or not,
but let's start from the Elon's
questions. Elon, if you are there,
would you mind you unmute yourself
and ask your questions. I Yes,
if not, I can, is the sum from when you
talk about the scaling law? He was asking,
is the sum form really the optimal he was
asking, how about the product power law,
like product form instead of the sound form?
Oh, can. Is there a chance to see the questions,
actually, is yes. Well, there is a, if you go to
the top of the yes, there's a options on the top,
and then
there's here at chat, yes, yes. If you
open that window, then you will see all the
all the questions in the chat? Oh, I see you see
that? Yes. Great. Okay, cool, yeah. Let's start
from the elons. The very first one is asking, is
the sum form really the optimal field? That's a
great father. That's a great question. It may not
be. So what people have observed is usually in a
lot of the regimes that they've studied, I think
the dominant ones are first the sums, like first,
you treat them semi independently, but there
might be correction terms that have to do with
this product. So by no means is is the form that
I wrote down kind of the the ground truth tried
and true form. It's more like functional fits
that people have done. And for certain problems,
it might be that indeed adding that product form
is actually very important and very good fit.
It just seems to be the case that for a
lot of these cases, the additive form is,
is kind of a dominant, good
fit. That's true. Well, okay,
all right. Our next question is by CO he's
asking, Could you comment on the divergent
behavior in the bottom left figure of the
taxonomy? You know what he's talking about.
Figures, yes, I think this one, yes. It
looks like the power loads diverse from
the data as one scales to larger width,
which is different from the other figures
that show continuing improvement.
Yes. That's also a great observation,
great question. It's actually just an artifact
of this experiment. So this experiment is kind
of done really. These regimes that I've talked
about are kind of asymptotic regimes. We don't
have a lot of control when n is of the order
of D. So there's this crossover that happens
in between these two regimes, and
that crossover regime is actually.
Uh,
described, and kind of known to
be described by double descent,
like phenomenon if, for example, your
model is not very well regularized.
So what you what you should focus on, I
think, for the theory, agreement is just
this left part of the of the experiment, because
this is trying to be in a regime where n is much
smaller than D. But just as a artifact of
our experiments, we had finite amount of D,
so there's a point at which N becomes of order d,
and then we wouldn't observe power loss scaling.
We see a crossover to a different behavior.
So actually, all of these curves are kind of,
what you would actually observe is like
this is sort of one half of one portion
of a regime. There's a crossover that happens,
and you would actually end up in this regime if
you were on the other side of that crossover.
Makes sense. Makes sense. Thank you very
much. Cool. Okay, next question is by Peter,
perhaps the alpha d to alpha W transition is
a function of a variance of the data versus
variance of the model parameters.
What do you think about that?
I'm not quite sure what the alpha
d to alpha W transition is. Is it
describing this transition?
Peter, if you're there, if
you can clarify your question,
use it. I don't know if you can hear me.
Yeah, we can hear you. Yeah, great. Thank you.
Yeah. I just, I have limited
experience in this field,
so I may be saying things that don't
make any sense, but it seems to me,
you're you're in, you're going from one
domain to another with these, you know,
with the difference in differences,
and it seems like the variance,
certainly the variance in the data, is going
to affect how well these things perform. And
you alluded to that. I think it's some
of your other slides. But there's also
the way the model is defined and how good your
model is, in terms of matching the real physics
of the model, there's going to be, there's going
to be variances in the in the model parameters as
well. And I would think that that that. So what
I'm trying to say is I could imagine a situation
where you have a very good bottle and there really
isn't a lot of variance in the model parameters.
You just have to figure out what they are
and if you have enough, and but you got a
bunch of variants in your data. And if you
get enough, the more and more data you get,
the tighter and tighter your your model
gets to predicting the model parameters.
And then, and then, the
other end of that regime is
you.
You're very good at measuring your your
your data, you have very little
uncertainty in your data.
So vice versa to what I just said, Sorry,
I don't know. I mean, I'm, I'm
just throwing that out there.
No, that's also a great question. So a
couple of points. So I think the variance
that you're looting. You alluded to, maybe
things that I would separate. So there's
like the variance of the data coming from
the fact that you sub selected some amount
of data there. So it's like a finite batch.
There's a finite size to it. Maybe you also
have uncertainty in your regression targets.
That's also a source of variance these things,
there's also another source of variance
from model parameters coming from the
choice of initialization and
randomness of the optimization.
So each time you run an optimization
and you choose the initialization so on,
you may get a slightly different model. So
these sources of variance are actually both in
the theory and these experiments have been sort
of averaged out. So if I go back to the way I
kind of define my setup, well, model, model error
versus data error. That's really what I'm going,
where I'm going to with this, and I think that's
what you're trying to to explain here. I hope
so, how they relate to it's actually, um, we
actually don't, I think touch about touch on that
too much. So the way I kind of defined, I didn't
go into this, but we are in our theory problem and
many of these other theory problems we average out
over those other sources of variance. So expect.
Over d here means averaging over the
draws of a finite size, D, capital D
samples. So I pick different batches,
and that does have different variances,
but I'm going to average over that to
get at least understand the average
effect. I'm also going to average over
the choice of random initialization
and in the experiments, what we're
doing, and you're you're right that
if you went out and just measured, we
do do a little bit of this averaging
to produce these empirical results. So,
like you would do multiple runs from
different initializations, we draw different
batches of data so we can match, you know,
so we can have some connection to the theory.
If you went out right now and ran a model
with you know, if you tried to do this
experiment, what you would find are plots
that are curves that actually do have a lot
more randomness in them because of that now,
especially in kind of smaller scale, smaller
data, smaller model size regimes. Now in these
other settings, like large language models, the
models and the data set sizes are so large that
essentially they become self averaging. So
they when they run like if they were to look
at the variance between different runs,
they don't see a lot of randomness. So
there is, depending on the absolute sizes of these
things, the amount of data and the model size,
there is this randomness or variance that I've
averaged out over here and you would observe
and that matters as well, and you're totally right
to ask about that. But there's a second part to
your question where you said, like, how well does
the model fit to the data? Kind of an alignment?
Does the model have the right inductive bias?
Does it align well to the data? And that's the
question that we're trying to get at in this
in this work, and others in theory. So like,
there you you want to average just to even
understand that problem, you want to average
out all the other sources of randomness. And
even there, the the value of alpha d and alpha
W in these two regimes that I mentioned, on the
off diagonal kind of categorizations or tables,
they do depend on this alignment. It's It's
essentially a how well your model aligns
to the data. And in this kernel setting,
there's actually a precise notion of that.
Okay, I do to paraphrase what you just said.
Well, I'm not exactly sure, but I I understand
where you're going. I'm not sure I understand
how it in the implications for the various
variables. But so when, when you're in a
the worse, I guess. What I'd like to the question
I want to ask is, the better your model is,
the better your model fits the actual data.
How does that change? That it sounds like that
reduces the the the alpha D or the
alpha W. Am I getting that right?
It increases it. So it's, there's
a steeper slope. In general,
there's, there's an addition, there's a constant
shift to all of these that we can't these are,
oh yeah, alpha is the power law parameter,
yeah. So that would make sense. It would the
higher the increase, the steeper the slope,
the better you get. Okay, yeah. So that's
true, and that amount of alignment,
so the constant shifts, we can't say much about
there theoretically, but at least the efficiency,
the rate of improvement. So the slope of these
lines does is governed by some notion of alignment
between the model and the data. And
actually, in the setting of kernels,
or Gaussian processes, you can that's that's
now well understood it, it is actually literally
like an alignment between the regression
values and eigenvectors of this matrix.
And so these would be, these are actually
things that you could measure ahead of time,
just to kind of have an assessment, at
least for kernels and Gaussian processes,
how well they you know whether they're good models
for the data just simply by looking at these
eigenvalues and looking at the Eigen vectors.
I think are you saying that you could use,
potentially use this to as an assessment of
the quality of your model for for kernels and
Gaussian processes? I think you could for neural
network models, there isn't an exact because of
these actual so this all is kind of based on
these infinite with results that I mentioned
so but for for finite with
neural networks, there's no such
kind of exact notion. There's maybe some
heuristics that are similar that you.
Could use, okay,
thank you.
Thank you. Thank you, Peter, and thank you
yes, for answering the question. And next,
do you have a time? By the way, it's I do. Okay,
awesome. Okay. The next question is by Kevin,
is there a way to initialize weight and
bias of a finite sized neural network so
that it approximates GP kernel
with desired hyper parameters.
Oh, that's a good,
interesting question, question. So if you take
the finite size network already and you just
choose the you can choose the initialization of
the weights and the biases. So there are these
variances, sigma squared w, sigma
squared B, that I didn't write down,
but I alluded to those show up in the kernel
as well. If you choose those to be the same,
then the finite size network with finite size
hidden layers already, you could use those
feature vectors to construct the kernel, and
it would be like a finite size approximation
to the kernel. It may not be the optimal one. So
there might be actually mathematically smarter
things that you could do. But it is true
that if you took those, if you just took,
for example, the representations of
a randomly initialized neural network
of finite size and took those
feature vectors and use them to
construct like a covariance matrix.
It would be like a it would be some
like a kernel matrix. That matrix,
as you make the width larger,
is exactly the kernel. So that is a finite size
approximation of it. I guess you can use that as
the initial weights and bias and then let it
train with the final size of the neural net,
whatever the data you have.
That might be a strategy. Well, that,
I guess so, for a GP,
for the neural net, not the GP, but
you could, you maybe say the question,
would you like to train the neural network in
a different way? Yeah. I mean, you start with
a weight and bias, which is corresponding to
the GP kernel with the desired hyper parameter,
and they use that and they as an
initial guess of rates and bias,
and then train them using, you know, the data
you have. Oh, so, so figure out this is like,
figure out the optimal hyper parameters,
weight and biases from the GP. Yeah,
yeah, motivated by the GP, yes, yeah, you you
could do you could do that. I actually suspect
it might not make too much of a difference. As
long as you're there are some pretty good regimes
of weight and bias variances for neural networks
that have been calculated, and as long as you're
kind of in that regime, so nothing too kind of
pathological. A lot of neural networks end up
giving good results, at least if you have
enough data and the model size is large enough,
so I suspect performance wise,
it might not have a big effect,
but you certainly could do that, right?
Kevin, do you have a follow up question?
I think, I think that's a good enough
explanation. Thank you so much. Okay,
next question is by Hannah Nelson.
She's saying I interpreted the graphs as
being in terms of train error. Should we
expect similar scaling results on data
which is outside our collective data?
That's a great question. Yeah,
so these graphs were the were
plotting the test error, but they it's true
that they're the evaluation and the training
data are from the same distribution. So
it's an in distribution setting. And if
you we're going to look at the test
error on out of distribution data.
So many works have done that.
They do see scaling laws, but it actually they can
get very different kinds of behavior.
So sometimes you know when the data,
it really just depends on the out of distribution
data and how well it aligns to the like pre
trained, trained model. So there are cases where
it improves with these other scaling variables,
but maybe after a certain scale, it
actually gets worse. Sometimes it just
improves monotonically. Sometimes it gets worse
monotonically. So there's been all sorts of
kind of types of behaviors observed,
and it's a great thing to do, I think,
but it's really there isn't much control on it.
So.
Okay? And she also has another
comment or question. Oh,
she says this is test data. Yes, okay,
okay. She's saying the more parameters doing
better with the scaling things. Reminds me
of accuracy boosts from Bootstrap
aggregations in three classifiers.
One other question from her, I've
seen it thrown around that the curves
or graphs of training laws can be used to
approximate the dimension of the manifolds
of distributions we are trying to learn.
In your opinion, is this a sound practice,
I think it's going to be a pretty noisy
estimate, unless maybe there's a specific
setting that you're thinking of where there are
some, like rigorous or semi rigorous results. I
kind of the plots that I showed where there
was a correlation between the exponent and
some measurement of the data manifold,
which I also didn't specify or get into
the details of was sort of loose. I think
estimates of manifold dimensionality are
are tricky to get right, and kind of
noisy on their own. And so I think
also the relationship between those two can be
maybe not super robust, unless there's maybe
a specific setting that you're
thinking of, to my knowledge,
awesome. Okay, I have a question. I have a
tons of questions. I was fascinated by your
Gaussian process, Connell, you know the method.
But let me ask another questions related to the,
you know, the slide you showed, introducing as
a active research area right now, about by
choosing certain training data selectively,
you can get much better scaling laws. Yeah,
and that one that is very attractive to us,
especially because the data we are getting
is usually associated with a high fidelity,
you know, the computational model simulations.
And, you know, just getting one data is is very
costly. So we, we want to choose those,
you know, the training data very wisely,
so that when we train the either neural network or
Gaussian model or some other data driven approach,
we would like to, you know, get the much better
scaling or convergence right with as few As data
as possible, since those data is coming from
physics simulations, we can utilize this a
lot of like the physical prior knowledge,
right? You know, the conservation of blow,
each physics has a different the basics property
to satisfy what would be your insight like?
You know, do you think you know,
using those domain knowledge from
the physics side and bringing into those sampling,
you know, training data sampling procedure
will will be essential to give us a this
much better scaling or convergence behavior?
Absolutely, yeah. I think, I do think that in
and
in low data regimes and small models,
certainly, the more inductive,
the more intuition you put into it, I
think the better, in general, it can do.
I wouldn't. I wouldn't, I think it's
kind of a, really an ongoing question,
what are the best heuristics
to use, even on the ML side?
So, so yeah, I would say, I think I would trust,
personally, if I were working in a domain I knew
well, I would trust my intuition, actually, for
how to do that sub sampling. At the moment, I can
say that in these regimes, often, well, there are
a number of heuristics out there since this paper
was published, but one thing that people have
been doing is kind of kind of, in a ways, it's
a form of cheating because, and I think this is
what this paper had done, which was kind of use a
large there was a larger model that was trained on
this data set that was used to suggest, kind of,
to pick the example. So maybe the places where
there was greatest error. I don't quite remember
the metric, but one of the catches was, and in a
lot of large scale ml settings, they kind of one
of the catches is that they might have already
access to some large model to point them to,
to which subset they might want
to keep, and then they might build
something like a foundation data set. So
just pruning the data, the original data.
Set that is, let's say, a benchmark data set
that everybody uses to some sub
sampled set that is then fixed,
and others would use that to train on. And one of
the things that's been kind of observed is that
maybe a lot of models, at least in
these other like kind of mainstream
ml communities that are used kind of share,
they have similar notions of what is a
good example or a hard example, you know,
a hard example or an easy example. So that,
therefore, the the large model that is sort
of like a teacher can kind of point, can that
signal that you would use from a larger model
that is like a teacher is actually useful for a
smaller model, but this might not transfer across
domains and so on. So this is one of the ways
that people have been kind of getting around this,
by kind of bootstrapping and kind
of using this having access to this
teacher model to produce that pruned data
set that then is actually pretty good for
small models that you would then train
on with fewer data, with fewer samples.
All right. Well, thank you, Yasmine, for
the wonderful talk and as well as the
wonderful Q and A sessions, I think we have
to let you go. We want to keep you longer,
but you know, we would like to
respect your your schedule too.
So we are so happy that you came to us and
then gave a wonderful talk, and, you know,
give us chance to discuss things. Hopefully
after this, if you allow maybe the collaboration
is encouraged, then we can actually do the
collaborations on some of the scientific
discovery through this question and wonderful
research on this neural network scaling law,
is it? Do you think it's, oh, yes, I'm happy
to chat further and discuss, okay, okay, yeah,
please. Audience, please reach out to Dr
Bari, and for the future collaboration,
I will do myself, you know, for the future
collaboration, reach out to you. Okay with that,
let's end our seminar today, and which
was wonderful seminar, okay, let me
push the stop button for the record.